(cloche)
- C'est la circonscription
la plus petite au pays.
Et c'est là que la nouvelle
cheffe des verts veut
faire sa grande entrée
à la Chambre des communes.
- Or we can have change.
- Du changement, c'est
qu'Annamie Paul propose
aux électeurs de Toronto-Centre.
L'avocate de 48 ans tentera pour
la troisième fois en trois ans
de faire passer au vert
un bastion libéral.
En octobre, la nouvelle cheffe
avait surpris en remportant
un tiers des voix lors
d'une élection partielle
déclenchée en pleine pandémie,
après la démission du ministre
libéral Bill Morneau.
ANNAMIE PAUL, cheffe
du Parti vert du Canada
- Si nous avons réussi à gagner
un tiers du vote et de placer
deuxième dans trois semaines
sous ces conditions, je crois
qu'on a toutes nos chances...
pour cette élection.
Hello!
- Yay! Annamie!
- Inconnue de la scène politique
il y a un an, Annamie Paul se
fait maintenant reconnaître dans
les rues de sa circonscription.
Mais la course ne sera pas
facile pour autant; la cheffe
des verts tente de déloger
Marci Ien, la députée
libérale sortante et
ancienne animatrice vedette.
Pour maximiser ses chances,
Annamie Paul a choisi de passer
la majorité de la campagne
électorale dans Toronto-Centre.
- Je suis quelqu'un qui cherche
à représenter une communauté
pour la première fois,
je n'ai pas le luxe d'aller
ailleurs et de ne pas...
connecter avec les gens ici.
- Une bonne question...
- Pour cette politologue,
les verts risquent gros
en mettant tous leurs oeufs
dans le même panier.
STÉPHANIE CHOUINARD, prof. agr.
Collège militaire royal Canada
- On ne s'attend pas,
du point de vue des verts,
à faire d'autres gains,
hormis Fredericton,
et probablement de conserver
ce qu'on a actuellement
en Colombie-Britannique.
- Et ce n'est pas
le seul obstacle auquel
les verts se butent.
Des divisions au sein
des troupes écologistes ont
récemment été dévoilées, lorsque
des membres du parti ont tenté
d'évincer leur nouvelle cheffe.
- Like less than one per cent
of people that I've spoken to.
- Ce militant vert soutient que
les électeurs ne se soucient pas
de la crise interne.
Mais dans ce quartier de
Toronto-Centre, où Annamie Paul
a fait sa meilleure performance
à la dernière élection,
des résidents pensent
le contraire.
Annamie Paul admet que
les dernières semaines ont
été pénibles, mais s'accroche.
- On doit se lever chaque jour
pour dire : je vais me battre
aujourd'hui, je vais travailler
fort aujourd'hui. Et tout ça,
on le considère le 21 septembre.
- Tenir bon jusqu'au jour
du scrutin et espérer que
de remporter un siège suffira
pour rallier les troupes.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, T